[Applauso]
io sono una psicologa e da un po di
tempo mi occupo di studiare le i
pazienti che hanno patologie oncologiche
e cardiovascolari e naturalmente una
delle delle domande su cui focalizziamo
molto spesso la nostra attenzione è di
andare a capire quanto peso hanno i
fattori psicologici nell'insorgenza e
nella prognosi di queste patologie
beh è abbastanza difficile andare a
capirlo perché come tutti sapete le
patologie sono caratterizzate da
moltissimi aspetti moltissimi fattori
però diciamo che andando a studiare
pazienti che hanno avuto una diagnosi di
tipo cardiologica o di tipo oncologica
ci siamo accorti che ci sono delle non
sono noi naturalmente anche la
letteratura lui dice che ci sono delle
caratteristiche che accomunano molto
questi pazienti
in particolare questi pazienti
generalmente raccontano che anche e
soprattutto nella fase precedente alla
diagnosi sono sempre stati persone che
si sono occupate tantissimo degli altri
prendendosi carico delle problematiche
degli altri prendendosi carico del di
aiutare a risolvere i problemi degli
altri hanno questa caratteristica di
personalità che compare molto spesso
sono persone e spesso ansiose che
tendono a vivere le situazioni con una
successiva rispetto al ad altri sono
persone che nella loro vita pre diagnosi
sono stati sottoposti soprattutto nella
patologia cardiologica ma non solo anche
in quella oncologica a stress molto
elevati sia in ambito lavorativo che in
ambito familiare e sono persone che a
volte hanno avuto dei periodi o delle
fasi depressive spesso tra l'altro non
valutate accuratamente o non presi in
considerazione accuratamente
quindi sembrerebbe che effettivamente ci
siano delle caratteristiche che sono
spesso presenti in questo tipo di
patologie
oggi parliamo di periferie e beh secondo
me la per il centro
se parliamo dell'essere umano il centro
dobbiamo essere siamo e dobbiamo essere
noi stessi ma se consideriamo tutto
quello che vi ho detto prima ma forse
quando ci preoccupiamo troppo degli
altri quando siamo soddisfatti da da
stress da ansia da preoccupazioni
eccessive
forse andiamo a spostare il centro dal
nostro io a quello che ci sta intorno e
quindi cominciamo a passare in una prima
fase di periferia in cui diamo molta
meno attenzione a quelli che sono i
nostri bisogni quelli che sono le nostre
volontà
se pensate che questo il discorso sia un
po esagerato e che i fattori psicologici
in fondo non possono avere così tanto
effetto sulla patologia beh vi faccio un
esempio che vale per tutti che è
l'esempio di questa patologia che una
patologia cardiaca che si chiama
sindrome di tako tsubo è una patologia
che è molto molto simile a un infarto ma
non è un infarto non non è causata dal
fatto che le arterie sono street e come
l'infarto ha una prognosi molto diversa
nel senso che spesso c'è un recupero
molto molto rapido e ed è caratterizzata
da un ingrossamento del del ventricolo
sinistro che assume questa forma di vaso
giapponese che appunto si chiama tako
tsubo beh quali sono le caratteristiche
principali di questa patologia sono due
fondamentalmente una è che colpisce
quasi esclusivamente donne e la seconda
è che insorge quando non ci sono altri
fattori di rischio evidenti ma
queste donne vivono una situazione
stressante molto forte
una situazione che può essere un lutto
che può essere una rapina che può essere
un licenziamento e quando non è
accompagnata da questo stress molto
elevato è sempre presente in persone
donne che come vi dicevo prima hanno
questa caratteristica molto comune
occuparsi preoccuparsi tantissimo degli
altri questo è quello che queste
pazienti raccontano quindi evidentemente
sì gli aspetti psicologici hanno un peso
rilevante oltre questo gli aspetti
psicologici possono portarci una seconda
forma di periferia che è una periferia
che va un po oltre la psiche è quella
periferia per cui sappiamo che spesso
persone molto stressate persone molto
ansiose persone depresse soprattutto
cominciano a mettere in pratica quelle
che chiamiamo cattivi abitudini live
tile bad live tile quindi fumo quindi
bear eccessivamente mangiare
eccessivamente non fare attività fisica
queste sono caratteristiche molto legate
alle problematiche psicologiche e ci
portano appunto a questo secondo livello
di periferia che è una periferia in cui
anche il fisico viene compromesso e per
poi arrivare a alla malattia
entrambi questi fattori psicologici e di
stili di vita accompagnati ovviamente ad
aspetti più biologici genetici di
predisposizione eccetera sono fattori
che portano alla malattia
la malattia che può essere considerata
la periferia della periferia se
consideriamo il sé come centro perché
periferia della periferia ma perché la
nel momento in cui ci viene
diagnosticato una malattia e in generale
qualsiasi tipo di malattia poi appunto
in particolare due patologie come la
patologia oncologica cardiologica che
portano a delle
modifiche importanti dello stile di vita
che portano a un cambio dell'aspettativa
di vita che portano soprattutto quella
oncologica all'ideazione di morte
beh uno tsunami emotivo è una situazione
in cui dal punto di vista emotivo non
sappiamo più come muoverci non capiamo
che cosa sta succedendo
non sappiamo più che decisioni prendere
siamo in una situazione di estrema
sofferenza una situazione in cui
dobbiamo necessariamente attuare dei
cambiamenti dei cambiamenti che spesso e
volentieri sono causati dai limiti sono
causati dalla non accettazione dal fatto
che io mi rendo conto che non sono più
quella di prima non posso più fare
quello che facevo prima e forse non
potrò mai più farlo fino ad arrivare a a
una situazione di rabbia estrema che è
la situazione in cui i pazienti si
chiedono perché proprio a me però questo
è il culmine questo è quello che
l'esperienza che i pazienti raccontano
ma quello che vediamo anche molto spesso
e che ci ha fatto vedere giulia molto
bene prima che credo non sia più qua
però ci ha fatto capire molto
chiaramente la malattia
dopo aver raggiunto questa pcie spesso
diventa un'opportunità credo che questo
dipinto rappresenti molto bene quello
che succede nelle i pazienti questo ce
lo sentiamo raccontare molte volte
soprattutto da pazienti donne per
l'appunto che hanno ricevuto una
diagnosi di patologia oncologica questo
quadro rappresenta è stato fatto in un
momento di grande sofferenza
dell'artista e rappresenta appunto
l'artista che frida kahlo che si sdoppia
e si sdoppia nel senso che c'è la frida
vestita di bianco con il vestito
sanguinante che è la free duck e soffre
e di fianco c'è invece la frida che era
felice e vuole tornare ad essere felice
come vedete queste due entità sono
sedute sulla stessa panchina si tengono
per mano e sono unite sono unite in
maniera molto significativa da questo
cordone che passa da un cuore all'altro
da un cuore che si sta spegnendo ha un
cuore che invece è rosso vivo e e quella
vestita di bianco quella che soffre ha
in mano una forbice
l'idea è proprio quella che quella che
vuole sopravvivere cioè quella con il
vestito colorato si voglia separare dall
altra entità e che questa separazione
sia una separazione dolorosa come
evidenziato dal fatto che neanche
riescono a guardarsi in faccia che però
questa separazione necessaria questa
separazione è quella che riporta alla
vita è quella che nel momento di
malattia nelle storie di malattia dei
pazienti delle pazienti è quella che
loro raccontano come ho capito che
dovevo ritornare al centro che dovevo
riprendere possesso della mia vita che
dovevo ricominciare a occuparmi di me
stessa
togliendo tutta quella periferia che è
stata fino adesso di occuparmi sempre
del resto di occuparmi sempre degli
altri di lavorare troppo di non avere
tempo per me e quindi appunto c'è questa
malattia che può essere considerata
sempre attraverso
grazie ai fattori psicologici che
possono essere stati la causa in questo
caso sono la forza di ritornare alla
normalità
effettivamente la letteratura ci dice
che soprattutto nel caso di pazienti
oncologiche soltanto il 5 15 per cento
di loro mostra una sintomatologia
ansioso depressiva dopo la malattia
mentre il 90 per cento dice che la
malattia con la malattia ha riportato
almeno un beneficio e nove su dieci di
queste pazienti dicono che c'è stato un
cambiamento nella loro vita che nel 30
per cento è un cambiamento importante
significativo ecco dove sta opportunità
ecco dove sta l'opportunità che le
pazienti dicono di scoprire nel momento
in cui si rendono conto che c'è il
rischio grosso di non poter andare
avanti nel momento in cui si trovano
davanti a un'esperienza che può essere
un'esperienza di morte beh noi cosa
abbiamo fatto abbiamo deciso di fare un
progetto che è un progetto un po
particolare lo stiamo facendo adesso e
abbiamo deciso di prendere delle donne
pazienti oncologiche e di portarle
sull'isola di un isola in isola nel
senso che l'isola su cui le portiamo e
l'isola di caprera che è un isoletta
della maddalena che è un'isola della
sardegna e di farle vivere
quest'esperienza loro vivere
quest'esperienza per una settimana in
cui fanno scuola di vela e due ore di
psicoterapia al giorno perché abbiamo
scelto questo posto e questa modalità
beh abbiamo scelto questo posto perché è
un posto estremamente isolato è un'isola
su cui non c'è niente se non il centro
velico è un'isola che non sa su cui non
c'è non ci sono distrazioni non c'è
possibilità di fare altro non ci sono
bar non sono ristoranti non c'è nulla
si arriva e le pazienti ancora prima di
arrivare e ci dicono una mela detto
l'altro giorno mi ha detto ma noi ci
conosciamo gia tutte ho detto ma no in
realtà non vi siete mai viste malto no
noi ci conosciamo gia tutte perché
abbiamo vissuto quell'esperienza che
comunque ci fa conoscere più di quanto
possiamo conoscere più
quell'altro è un'isola dove non ci sono
infrastrutture dove non ci sono
sovrastrutture nel senso che si è tutti
uguali ci si spoglia di tutto e si vive
questa settimana intensa nell'ultima
foto vedete che anche la psicoterapia è
abbastanza particolare nel senso che
viene fatta in una specie di capanno e
ed è una settimana molto intensa in cui
le pazienti accomunate da questa loro
esperienza raccontano il loro vissuto ma
soprattutto fanno qualcosa che non hanno
mai fatto nessuna di loro è mai stato in
barca a vela e la barca a vela è una
esperienza molto particolare
abbiamo parlato anche di limiti barca a
vela per pazienti che hanno avuto una
patologia così importante che spesso
hanno anche delle sofferenze fisiche
vuol dire veramente decidere di buttarsi
e di mettere in gioco tutte le loro
forze per riprendere ritornare al centro
di se stesse oltre a questo la barca a
vela è una è stata scelta perché ricca
ricchissima di metafore la prima
metafora eh beh sicuramente nel momento
in cui si esce in barca per la prima
volta si scopre che niente sulla barca
si chiama con lo stesso nome con cui si
chiama terra e la stessa cosa che
succede durante la malattia quando viene
fatta una diagnosi per la prima volta il
paziente si trova davanti a un medico
che spesso usa dei termini che non sono
noti che il paziente non capisce
parla di terapie che il paziente non sa
che cosa sono e e quindi c'è confusione
totale la stessa confusione che si crea
sulla barca si esce la prima volta che
si esce ci si rende conto che si
abbandona a quello che è il porto sicuro
la terra in una situazione in cui non sa
governare una barca anche se
naturalmente sulla barca ci sono gli
istruttori e
e soprattutto si capisce una cosa che
bisogna affidarsi a un'entità che è
totalmente incontrollabile che al vento
e di nuovo è quello che succede nella
malattia non c'è niente di controllabile
nella malattia
quello che si può fare però il vento tra
l'altro è un è una forza significativa
contro con cui si può fare tutto tranne
una cosa andargli contro
e infatti per andare in barca e si può
soltanto cercare di aggirare il vento e
di utilizzarlo per arrivare dove bisogna
arrivare si scopre che per arrivare da
un punto all'altro quindi per
raggiungere la meta bisogna fare una
serie di percorsi che possono cambiare
cambiano continuamente a seconda di dove
viene il vento stessa cosa che succede
durante la vita quotidiana nella
malattia e in barca
succede che bisogna fare quello che si
chiama strambata ogni tanto la strambata
è un'operazione complicata che sconvolge
tutta la barca e le pazienti spessissimo
si rendono conto che nella vita di
strambate ne hanno fatte ma soprattutto
dopo questa esperienza decidono di farne
decidono di farne con un unico scopo
quello di tornare a essere a rimettere
se stesse al centro e quindi soprattutto
quello che si insegna in questa
settimana e che non è utile cercare di
controllare ciò che non è controllabile
ma è utile cercare di usare tutte le
risorse che si hanno a disposizione per
raggiungere la meta è un'esperienza che
porta a dei risultati per ora abbiamo
fatto tre settimane porteremo 150
pazienti è un'esperienza che porta a
quelli che noi e le pazienti hanno
definito dei piccoli miracoli succedono
cose che non si aspettavano succedono
cose che non erano ormai successe nella
vita e perché fondamentalmente
c'è un coinvolgimento così forte
psicologico che scambia e si decide
abbiamo avuto delle pazienti che ci
hanno detto che per la prima volta
quando gli è arrivata l'onda addosso
sono riuscite a piangere e non avevano
mai pianto dalla diagnosi fino a quel
momento quindi è un'esperienza
bellissima io ve lo vorrei far veder vi
vorrei far vedere due minuti di video
perché quello che racconto io è
sicuramente molto poco rispetto a quello
che raccontano loro purtroppo il video è
un po disturbato dal fatto che c'è il
vento ma il vento appunto è parte
integrale
vai come è andata la giornata oggi
contenta superato le onde imponente e
priva sono pro ce l'ho fatta io ti dico
cosa che tu lo puoi fare da sola
ok credimi
grazie
e cambiata maggiormente che si perdono
ma non puoi la propria immagine in
realtà si arriva cosi veramente contano
tutto il resto sì c'è però
è qualcosa che non è così fondamentale
[Musica]
vai
cliccate per fortuna in un tempo siamo
state obbligate a a far emergere molto
più rapidamente tutta una serie di
questioni che magari singolarmente
abbiamo rimandato riportato lasciato
perdere invece qui siamo in un qualche
modo obbligate a per me dal punto di
vista relazionale anche perché siamo
contenti eravamo con tele sconosciute
anche una situazione che non è mai
piaciuto sono diversi quello che se ne
può trarre solo beneficio perché ti fa
leggere delle cose
da dei punti di vista che non avevi
contemplato ed è utilissimo questo
[Musica]
sì mi siamo tanto fortissimi queste sono
tutte pazienti che hanno da poco
superato la fine della terapia e quindi
che insomma non è passato molto tempo e
devo dire che ci insegnano ogni
settimana ci insegnano che veramente
vale la pena tornare al centro di noi
stessi prima che succeda tutto questo
[Applauso]